nouveaux rebondissements dans la faire
inscrire pâle un troisième homme de
nationalité russe a été inculpé au
royaume uni dans l' enquête sur le
présumé empoisonnement en 2018 d'un ex
agent double russe la correspondance à
moscou deux vérins goffman
moscou condamne toutes les tentatives du
royaume uni de rejeter la faute sur la
réussite dans la sphère skripal a fait
savoir la porte parole de la diplomatie
russe mariya zakharova pour elle le fait
que la sphère skripal reviennent
maintenant sur le devant de la scène est
une manière de préparer la rencontre des
ministres des affaires étrangères russe
et britannique qui doit avoir lieu en
marge de l'assemblée générale de l'onu
dans les prochains jours je vous propose
d'écouter
en même temps les dirigeants du royaume
uni continuent d'utiliser la sphère
skripal comme un outil de pression sur
notre pays en réactivant les sentiments
antirusses dans la société britannique
et en construisant tout ce concept
russophobe qui est ensuite transférée
aux médias britanniques
nous condamnons fermement toutes les
tentatives de londres de rendre moscou
responsable de ce qui s'est passé à
salisbury et insistons pour que soit
menée une enquête professionnelle
objective et impartiale sur cet incident
nous réaffirmons également notre volonté
de coopération sectorielle au niveau des
forces de l'ordre et des experts en la
matière
la russie comme auparavant et déterminés
à établir la vérité et en passant notre
position n'a pas changé elle reste la
même nous voulons vraiment établir la
vérité sur ce qui s'est passé et nous
continuerons à exiger des autorités
britanniques de fournir des informations
officielles complètes ainsi que de
respecter leurs obligations juridiques
internationales en ce qui concerne
l'accès consulaire à nos concitoyens au
clash au magret h demain pour marié
zakharova s'est fait plus de deux ans
que le royaume uni se sert de la sphère
skripal pour compliquer les relations
bilatérales entre les pays selon la
porte parole de la diplomatie russe
londres a toujours refusé une enquête
conjointe de la faire malgré les
demandes répétées de la russie marié à
carvin a conclu en disant qu'il était
grand temps que londres dit la vérité
sur la sphère skripal